(laughter)
- [Mark] All right. What is your name?
- Royalty.
- Royalty?
- Yes.
- [Mark] Royalty, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from?
- [Royalty] Well, I grew up in Watts.
- [Mark] South Central?
- [Royalty] Yes.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family,
you grew up with both your parents?
- [Royalty] Yes, my step-dad and my mom.
- And how was your childhood?
- Well, in the beginning it was okay.
But then, we ended up in foster care.
And, like, we were separated.
- Who's we? You and your...
- Me and my siblings.
- Oh, I see.
- It was like, six of us.
I basically was taking care of my sisters,
because my step-dad
had a gambling problem.
- Oh, okay.
- And, my mom, she
basically dipped, like left,
like for sometimes weeks, sometimes days.
And I was left taking care of my siblings.
- Are you the oldest?
- Yeah. With a twin.
- Oh, I see. Okay.
- So...
I was just raised taking care of them
at a young age. I was like six years old,
taking care of my siblings.
- And then how were your teenage years?
- Actually, I spent- thirteen years old
from juvenile hall. I
went from juvenile hall
to the compound.
Then, from the compound
I went to prison.
- What were you in juvenile
hall for? And prison?
- Uh, for killing the
person that sodomized me.
- Who'd you kill?
- My foster dad.
- Oh, so in the foster home you got-
he was molesting you?
And how did you murder him?
- Um, I found the gun with somebody that
took me in. Basically
he knew what I wanted
to do right then and then.
And, woke- went to the place and
woke him up. Gave him
a choice and told him
if... you have a choice, like, you either
going to like do it yourself while I
have a gun pointing, or I'm going to do it
because either way you have to go, because
you shouldn't have to do that to
a twelve-year-old girl.
You know, like...
- Wow.
- It's- because, it really fucks with you,
you know?
- Absolutely.
- And to do that to me
and then throw me out
with nothing? Like, no
clothes, I was just trash.
You know, it's devastating.
- Yeah. So you ended up
in prison for how long?
- From thirteen, I
didn't get out until 25.
I'm basically 27 now.
- Oh my god, so you just got out.
- And it's like, I had dreams, you know.
To become a singer, write poems,
and all that, and it was basically like
he took that away from me.
- [Mark] Yeah, you spent half your life
in prison or jail.
So, do you still stay in touch
with any of your family?
- [Royalty] Most of them I do.
But me and my twin
basically don't get along.
Because we always argue, she felt because
when I was a newborn I had health issues.
I basically, when Mom gave birth to me,
I basically flat-lined.
I stopped breathing,
I turned blue and purple,
I was pronounced dead
for three hours. And my family basically
was treating me like royalty, you know.
Whenever I needed
something they was there,
and she hated me because of that.
- [Mark] Oh.
- [Royalty] So, I don't talk to her.
My step-dad, I talk to. My real dad,
I'm barely just getting to know.
- And where are you living now?
- Right now, I'm living in a tent.
- In Skid Row?
Are you using any drugs that are out here?
You're not using?
- Maybe I smoke weed. Because I'm still
trying to do my music, and everything.
But it's hard when you have
that record on you.
- Absolutely.
- It's hard to get a job.
- It's gonna follow you everywhere you go.
- Yeah.
- And how do you support yourself now?
- Right now, I have two bikes.
One, I sell.
I sold my bikes and sometimes
family or friends I sing for
look out for meeting and..
- Get out, dating guys like a lot
of the girls do? You do that, too?
Yeah. It's a common story down here.
- Yeah, I used to do it.
But then I felt like I was better,
I felt degraded. And basically it was
giving me flashbacks. So, yeah, I stopped.
- And do you have any friends?
- I have very few.
- You kind of had a big chunk of your life
taken away from you, so it's hard to
make friends, right?
- Yeah, because it's hard to trust.
- What kind of thoughts
go through your head?
What do you wish was different about your
childhood that might
have- I mean, certainly
not having a step-dad molesting you would
be a big one.
- I wish I could have
thought the situation
out instead of not thinking and
just doing it. I could have thought
about the situation better.
- Did you tell, was it
your mom, that could
have done something?
- My step-mom passed away-
- It was your foster mom, your foster mom
could have done something, right?
- She passed away.
- Oh, so the step-dad-
- She passed away in my lap,
she had a seizure.
And right after she passed away,
that's when all hell broke loose.
- Oh jeez.
- And all the thoughts
ran through my head,
like, did he do it? Because he showed
no emotion. So, basically I was just
on my own. Like, foster homes don't care.
The social workers, they
say they do, though.
- You've never had anybody
that cared for you.
- No. The only person
that cared- showed that
cared was my son.
- Oh, you have a son?
- I have a four year
old. About to be five.
In a foster home.
- He's in a foster home.
Do you ever get a chance to talk to him,
or see him?
- They took him away
because he's artistic.
- Autistic?
- And they say with my anger issues and
me having blackouts that I'm not
able to take responsibility and take care
of my son unless I have joint custody.
- When you have blackouts,
what causes blackouts?
- My anger. I guess
from when I flat-lined,
I just have blackouts to
where I can't remember
and then I have seizures
because I had brain trauma.
- From your birth?
- Yes.
- Are you on medication for that?
- I had supposed to take it, but I don't.
I mainly smoke weed
to basically calm it.
That's it.
- Do you have any plans for your future?
Anything you'd like to see happen?
- Basically follow my career, my dream.
I already started writing poems
and putting them on Hello Poetry,
and I'm already doing music,
recording myself, and I love that.
- Is writing music and poetry, you find it
helpful, therapeutic for-
- Yeah
- What you're going through?
- Yeah, I'll bet it is.
- [Royalty] It actually keep me calm.
Especially music, like when I get
nervous or something
I start singing.
- Yeah, you're a beautiful singer.
I heard you sing just now.
(laugther)
While I was setting up.
- Thank you.
- All right Royalty,
well thank you so much
for talking to me and sharing your story.
- Thank you.
- And good luck with your life now that
you're finally free.
(laughter)
- Yes.